hey guys I got a comment recently on my
origami boomerang tutorial from the
hybrid ink and he asked is there any way
you can interlock the origami boomerangs
you could find the tutorial by clicking
on this link up here once you've done
that you'll notice that yes on the front
of the boomerang there is a little bit
of a pocket and if you wanted to you
could slide one boomerang into the other
one and get something like this do you
want to do this no because this will
either a split up in midair and become
two boomerangs which probably won't come
back to you bail B fall to the ground
epic fail or C poke someone's eye out
ah what you do want to do is to take two
of the boomerangs and grab a little bit
of tape and I'm going to show you how to
make something like this the super boom
or a flame juggler 117 initially made a
video response with this model but took
it down was not available for comment
why do you need to make the super
boomerang one it's free - it's the
coolest thing I've ever made with my
bare hands
4 you can throw it with your right or
your left hand 3 once you have the two
boomerangs it only takes about 30
seconds to tape them together 5 if you
have a low ceiling it doesn't matter
this flies in a horizontal plane 6 you
don't need to be a ninja to do it but if
you want to become a ninja just click on
this video here by Ryan Higa or you can
click on my video here on how to make a
ninja star and 7 it's free warning this
is only free of you have printer paper
and tape I'm not responsible for you
slaying or stealing paper or tape from
someone take two boomerangs that you
already know fly well and hold them both
with the same side facing towards you as
you'll see I'm holding this diagonal
line with the pocket facing towards us
same thing with the one on the right
just like I showed at the end of the
origami boomerang tutorial you don't
want to hold the one on the left like
this on the one on the right like this
with the flap hold them both the same
side facing towards you then you're
going to flip or turn the one on the
right
180 degrees until you're holding them
corner to corner now you're going to
slide the one on the left over the one
on the right so that these creases or
lines here overlap
when you do that the corner of the top
boomerang will be in between this corner
here made by these two edges and the
corner of the bottom boomerang will be
here in between these two edges of the
top boomerang once you have it just like
that we're going to put two pieces of
tape on the top one here on this edge of
the corner and one here so take two
pieces of tape maybe like an inch long
and put one on this edge and then put
one on this edge flip it over and we're
going to do the same with this bottom
corner however on the bottom here you'll
see that we have that flap so what you
want to do is to take another piece of
tape and we're just going to tape this
edge here which doesn't have the flap
and then for the last piece of tape take
it all you need to do is to lift up this
flap here and put the piece of tape down
like this underneath that flap press
down so it looks like this so you
basically just don't want to put any
tape on this edge then all you need to
do is to just press downwards on it make
sure it's flat and you've completed the
super boomerang before I show you how to
throw the super boomerang I'm going to
give you a few tips for throwing the
single one a little better always hold
it with this diagonal fold facing
towards you if you throw it upside down
like this it's going to hit the ground
put the tip of your finger on top of the
edge here and hold it between your
middle finger and thumb just like this
now it's all about giving the boomerang
a nice spin so you're going to flick
your wrist and let it roll off the tip
of your finger also don't throw it
horizontally angle it up a little bit
maybe at a thirty or forty-five degree
angle and if you're hitting the ceiling
just kneel down closer to the ground
like that in super slo-mo to throw the
boomerang with your right hand again
make sure that this diagonal line is
facing towards you and you're going to
grasp one of these arms between your
pointer and middle finger and let the
center of the boomerang on the back lie
on the rest of your fingers like this
just to give it some support so it's not
being bent and you can also throw it
like a frisbee if you want to that's not
the best way that it flies though to
make the boomerang go in a circle again
hold it the same way between your
pointer and middle finger let the center
of it rest on your other fingers and
this next arm of the boomerang should
actually rest on your palm like that
hold it vertical but tilt it to the left
a little bit and when you throw it's
going to circle to the right so hold it
like this tilt it to the left maybe I'd
like a 70 degree angle but you can
experiment with it and then rotate your
hand outward similar to like when you're
doing a yo-yo if you make it sleep just
let it roll
out of your hand to throw the boomerang
with your left hand instead of holding
it so that this diagonal fold is on
front and all these arms are slanted to
the right just flip it over like this
then hold it the same way except tilt it
to the right now like this and snap your
wrist outwards
you go you evoke at I'm trying to make a
video here ow ah